just sitting there and Sam Jackson
Samuel Jackson sitting just in front and
Quentin just before by category was
announced Sam turned around to me and
went Tim when you lose write say 'mother
Reservoir Dogs I think my agents kind of
initial impulse was to look at mr. pink
or mr. blonde which were you know
Madison and Steve Buscemi's they felt
that I'd be more interested in that but
I wasn't at all it was interested in mr.
orange because I would be an English
actor pretending to be an American
playing a cop who was pretending to be a
robber so I liked the four levels of
deceit that that that would make me go
through I also thought it would be
hugely more challenging and and so I was
intrigued by it and then met when I met
with Quentin that was that same as now
it feels the same it feels that that the
the atmosphere on set is fun and
excitement and enjoyment and you know
very very creative but the one thing
that Quentin has that I find is not
necessarily true of a lot of writers
directors is that he's already done your
improvising for you I mean if someone
comes to you and you do it it's there
and he can go cut no no no no no and I
see I've seen him do it and he said it
to me he says through all of his actors
it's on the page give me what I wrote
they can smell it sure is that [ __ ]
dark
he's already done so much for you you
know that you know when your phone rings
and it's him on the other end you just
your fingers crossed you know so we've
shot the thing and think five weeks you
know and I think the very very little
money involved
I remember Harvey Keitel saying to me
what do you think I think I said I think
this is really good yeah me too done
Ching said and but we had that feeling
that we were in something great and made
a lot of that obviously had to do with
the script but a lot of it had to do
with Quentin - and we were in we were we
were in a big we were at the beginning
of something grand
you know in the in a not pretentious
play been something great Pulp Fiction
he read me the whole script one night or
as he was working on it he was he would
do that a lot so I had an inkling of
what the film was gonna be and what it
was gonna be about and the layering of
it and the structure of it and so forth
I think he came at me for a different
character initially and then he switched
tracks I think had a lot to do with
Amanda Plummer because I knew Amanda we
were off to a premiere of Fisher King
which she was in and I knew she was
always late for everything and this
scatterbrained and stuff so I said send
the car to my house pick me up first
because I was gonna take her there I was
gonna be a date or whatever and then
we'll come around and we'll get you came
around got her she was fast asleep so we
load her in into the car got her there
and and she was so dizzy but it was her
night and then Quentin was there and I
said I'd like to work with Amanda as
long as she's got a really big [ __ ]
gun in her hand and he went done did he
built those two characters right I love
those characters absolutely love them
[Music]
made in Britain that was my first job
with cameras involved here originally
the way I got the job I was working I
was calling myself an actor and which is
hilarious and selling advertising over
the phone to people who couldn't afford
it and cycling back and forth to where I
was staying
in the middle of the night and I got a
flat tire and went to a theater to see
if I could get a tire repair kit or
something
and they told they didn't have that but
they told me about these auditions and I
went in I got it through nefarious means
I met with Alan Clark who's one of the
best who was one of the best directors
of of actors I've ever worked with it
was I supposed to beat them I think of
her and noon or something like that so I
turned up at 11:30 left out half an hour
early so I and they said oh you're early
come back in a half an hour and I went
oh okay I'll just go wait in the park
across the road and I went over into the
park and I knew that their windows
looked down into that Park and I kind of
I did a bit just got into character a
little bit and then luckily a mate of
mine from a band who had a huge peacock
hairdo came through the park and me a
name started mucking about and then we
got stopped by the police and searched
and all the usual then I went in and did
the audition and got the job and then we
went off and in the last day of filming
Alan Hart said to me you know why you
got the job at oh yeah oh yeah you were
watching me out that window
anyway you passed it I said yeah and
then he got me my next job so it's good
do you cough you gotta you know keep
your wits about you a lot well I would
say
the hit it was complicated because Joe
Strummer from the clash was gonna play
Myron and then he couldn't do it because
there was here to be with the band for
some reason the character was based on
bullies that I'd known at school bullies
that I'd known outside school and polish
commandos who my dad had told me about
from the second world war which was
where all the razor blades in the color
came from and little steel Blakey's
which we used to have when we were kids
which they'd put all around their shoes
and sharpened them so they'd take your
skin off it's all about street fighting
and about football hooligans so that
with some really bad fashion thrown in
and and a very bad dye job that was
character it was my first time on an
aeroplane I've traveled there with John
Hurt I was I was working with John and
Lauda del Sol and Terence Stamp it was
crazy and I couldn't drive and I was
playing the driver they were trying to
teach me how to drive and there was one
particular scene where I Drive around a
windmill pull up on the top of a kind of
mountainous hill it's windmills and
distance all very um sort of Spanish and
we get out I have a conversation I take
a pee and then we have a little moment
and I'm get back in a car and drive away
that's me and Terence and John pull out
like a cut and test it someone gets in
the car drives it back around to the
other side of the windmill puts it on
its mouth drive back in again
and after about three three or four
takes Terence who's in the back Terrace
it's um you're doing really good put it
on this marked yeah sure right so drive
around with Milt and I put it on its
marks and I hit the accelerator instead
of the brake and went straight into the
camera not the camera off the dolly the
camera went down the side of the
mountain
I carried on down the side of the
mountain we turn turn it's damp and John
hurt cracking up in the back but I
thought I was gonna we were all gonna
die I went all the way down to the
bottom of this mountain and managed to
get it to to a hole the first thing at
my mouth was I'll never work again and
they will piss themselves laughing in
the back and then everyone signed the
car and still it was trashed
signed a car stood around it and took
pictures and the producer said sure
every time said insurance and we moved
on it and that was one of my first
experiences of filmmaking
[Music]
plan of the apes one of the first things
I did when I was trying to be an actor
was I went and did some movement classes
with the guy who was the one of the apes
and also in charge of the ape movement
on Greystoke the Tarzan movie a million
years ago Planet of the Apes came up
they'd brought in and not you know a
second second movement guy from he was a
catcher flier and a catcher insert de
soleil and they brought him in and he
was my height built like a brick
[ __ ] and me and him just got
carried away with moving we started just
because I could you know there's plenty
of plenty of down time on any movie so
we just spent four it was just having
the best time
off camera all the time I got that guy
in to do to be my stunt me my character
fade and so I would come in in the
morning we both be fully in makeup go
with Tim go this would be the scene I
said what about if he if he came up off
the back of a horse up through the
window into there you know and we would
just make make [ __ ] up you know and
Terry his name's Terry notary could do
it it's extraordinary
also he was the he was the might of my
stunt double but he didn't need the
muscle suit me and Tim really wanted to
me I saw him recently by the way Tim
Burton it's just a you know crossing at
the airport type situation but we were
still talking about it's like the movie
that we wanted to make was so dark and
twisted but unfortunately we weren't
allowed to make that one
[Music]
Vincente the fear when they told me what
it who it was to play I because I've
been at art college I had studied him
and he was woman he was my father's
favorite painter I felt I was too young
to play it I went to see Bob in his
hotel fancy pants London and said I
think I'm too young and then he said in
that case you've got the job and I
couldn't I couldn't really fight him on
it we went to Holland first myself and
Paul Reis he was playing fear Vincent's
brother and we arrived and there was a
big party and we were bit bored and we
didn't have any money so we went to Bob
and say give us some money we're going
to go into Amsterdam proper he gave us a
wad of cash and said come back with
characters which we did so he'd spent a
couple of days roaming around in
Amsterdam completely out of our depth
with the whole place and then came back
with ideas about what our character
should be and then launched into it and
it was quite a long shoot during we were
given licence to improvise but we're and
play with the dialog and then gradually
Bob said okay you go away you've got as
group fact as you go away work the
dialogue what you want to do what how
you would play a scene about such and
such an event and then come back to me
in the morning and we'll shoot that it
was actually one of the most fun times
I've had as an actor I mean I've been
fortunate because I've had a lot of them
[Music]
Rosencrantz and Guildenstern are dead I
was away I was going to do some crap
movie and I was in Dubrovnik not making
a movie with my girlfriend at a time we
were just hanging about and then the
film got cancelled yes so but while I
was there I got this script and it was
raising her and I knew the play and I
was a very very keen fan of Tom starts
and you know it was an extraordinary
thing so I was incredibly nervous and I
went over to Tom's place in London when
I got back and Gary open the door I was
like oh [ __ ] so we went in me and him
and we were just sitting with with Tom
and we were mucking about and catching
up really and tom was just like okay
they are questions that you have to ask
questions
and then Tom said can't give you a lift
anywhere and I said I'll yeah I gotta
get to the station to get a train home
so he took me to the station and on the
way to the station he said listen I have
to say I would love to give you this job
but the powers that be Danny day-lewis
is being offered ahead of you and it was
he said I'm afraid you're not it's not
going to be for us but you know thanks
for coming in and all that stuff I was
gutted that night Danny was doing Hamlet
and he had a bit of a meltdown on stage
and he thought he saw his father and all
of that stuff for real and took a break
from acting so I got the job so I've
always odd Danny big time which of
course he doesn't need me
but I've always owed him fig and for
that because he that's how I got the job
I have terrible stage fright so probably
not
Rob Roy I actually thought I was gonna
get fired it was something I had net had
no experience of that that kind of class
and that you know that world and you
know that kind of a feat upper class
honest the FOP thing which was very much
a thing in the United Kingdom whatever
you may call it at that time anyway I
started doing it and you know within it
within a week you couldn't get me out of
a room without bowing 25 times you know
I was having a fine time but I got on
the phone to my agent I said the
Americans are coming over I'm gonna get
fired
can you see if there's something that I
can go on to if can you find me another
job because they're gonna they're gonna
fire me and it was my first real payday
on that movie I that was from that movie
I most buy a house which was awesome
they kept me on and well Liam Liam was
you know the the star of the movie and
he was off in the hills with his kilt on
while they were off doing that I was
working with Bill Hobbs and his guys
down on the lower level in in a school
gym sword-fighting and fell in love with
that and one of the hardest things that
we had to do on that was I was with a
lightweight fast fast moving sword
Liam's characters saw Rob Roy was
broadsword not maybe not a broadsword
but very heavy I kill him in a second
yeah so the idea was that I was stinging
him and that I was around him and
embarrassing him and bringing him to a
point where he's on his knees at which
point he has to cheat to win and that's
not what I'm expecting and that's what
gets me we spent months working on on
that me and his stunt double it was
totally unexpected
and funny um me and missus got to go to
the Oscars and you got you got free
frocks so no it was it was utterly
terrific but this is this is my fondest
memory of it just sitting there and Sam
Jackson Samuel Jackson sitting just in
Quentin just before by category was
announced Sam turned around to me and
went Tim when you lose right say
[ __ ] like that
and I was I connect up but didn't do it
and it's my only only regret because of
course you'd be in the frame and it with
the idea of sitting the game [ __ ] cut
and it would have been but only Sam
could get away with it funny games I
read it and said no I don't want to go
through that I didn't want to have that
experience at that time and my agent
said to me get the previous one I think
you've already sent it to me to look at
this and I saw it went oh okay [ __ ] and
so I said yes doing a shot shot remake
of a film must be made before is
complicated there's a 12-minute take in
there that is exactly the same beat for
beat the same as what was originally
shot you had to not only suffer the
circumstances that the family were under
but you had to portray that within a set
of circumstances that were years past
and in a different country and with a
different group of people it was very
very hard to do very disturbing plus the
boy that was in it a little boy played
our son it was very hard because he
looked just like my one of my sons
and it was a bit much I love working
with Naomi Watts she has such a wicked
sense of humor because she's English
Australian kind of thing and she's just
you know she was sticking her fingers in
his sandwiches and stuff she's a very
weird human I adore her
lie to me when I was in England I when I
first started I wanted to experience
different things so even after I was
doing after the hit I would do a small
part in the television thing that was
shot on the floor in in in the studio
just to see what it felt like just in
case that happened to me then I would go
and do a radio play and then I would go
you know so I would find out how these
things felt so just in case they happen
down the line so I kind of applied the
same principle to lie to me I'd never
done it so I thought I should try that
and I really enjoyed it I mean it we did
I think in the end we did 58 episodes of
it and you know the one thing I did
discover because I don't generally watch
what I do few exceptions
I would dip back into it and go oh my
god just so over the top pull it back so
you could do that with that with in a
long-form kind of Network series and I
had a really really good time I worked
with an incredibly creative people it
was a difficult thing to keep that
science being interesting it was based
on Paul Ekman's some studies he it's
it's about the language of lying the
language of deceit it's a body language
expert so he can look at you like he
could look at me now and tell me and
tell you when I'm bullshitting and when
I'm not and and there are certain things
that across all cultures are tells and
he can spot them no you could do the
course like the actors were given a shot
at it some of them did it and I said no
way I don't want to know where my kids
are lying to me I don't want to have any
of that
[Music]
hopefully it was a it was like a theater
troupe it had that feeling to it so we
went and we did this stuff up the
mountain all the exteriors that he could
grab in the snow and all of that stuff
and then we we did that version of the
movie
and then which was the complete set
built and so when we didn't have good
enough snow who go inside and start
those scenes and then we came down to LA
and it was 90 degrees and we and he
refrigerated the studio it was colder in
LA than it was up in the mountains to be
honest so we could see how bright it was
it was great I mean it felt like we were
in a plane we did a long run of a play
well well well looks like Minnie's
haberdashery is about to get cozy for
the next few days when the first version
of it was leaked I was rehearsing a play
and hateful it was already on he was you
know getting ready he was pulling all
these people together as to he was doing
his casting and then it went it got
leaked out and and I got a call from him
at theater I was in rehearsal and he was
scrapping it he was I'm done
screw this and he was really really
angry I talked to him I said you know go
shake the trees go jump up and down but
you're crazy if you let whoever did this
you know ruin such a great kind of party
you're about to have he was really
really upset and then he did a rejigger
of it and then we did this great reading
in downtown which was just a fantastic
night well he did that to say goodbye to
it because he was this he did that of
the original script yeah and because he
couldn't do that ending so he say
goodbye to it that way
tin star we found very quickly that with
the core family Genevieve O'Reilly plays
my missus and Abigail Laurie plays my
daughter we found that we connected
which was a lot of that was down to the
producers casting she put three people
in a room that could that just it made
sense
so we'd improvise and it was encouraged
it was it was encouraged that we would
muck about and only in the scenes that
we were only in the scenes that we were
in you know or I was in with other
actors we would play around the stuff
and it wasn't it was like go for it guys
is great and it had so it had a kind of
loose quality about it I don't know
about other people's stuff but it was
what we did when we were together so it
might have been a habit that I fell into
and then we did one episode in that
season episode 9 which with a director
that I'd worked with in England young
director we got him out and put him on
it and it was a a kind of flashback
episode of a standalone episode so we
improvised the entire thing we would
meet as actors in the same way I did
with Altman and with Mike Lee when I
work with him before and we would what
would you do under this circumstance
what would you say what would you not
say how would you behave and and so and
then the following day we would shoot it
and still it would be flexible when we
were on the floor as long as we deliver
the episode it was good and I and it was
one of the better episodes in the season
in the first season so when we went to
the second season with a couple of
notable exceptions which were script
heavy
we took that notion and ran with it so
that the that kind of feeling that kind
of loose back-and-forth feeling even
under the most dire of circumstances as
it ratcheted ratchets are still plays so
and you can change on the day what
you're going to do and so on which so
the crew had to be very patient with us
and they were it's difficult because
your day ends and then your day begins
and then it begins again so you that it
was it was extraordinary long hours
because you had to get ready for the
next day's stuff even if you'd finished
at midnight or something so you
you know all you get there early in the
morning and you get we generally meet in
my trailer for coffee and and score what
would you do how about if the what about
if you did this and then I would be
meeting with with Allison Jackson
producer and just Connells script
supervisor in my flat and we come up
with ideas and then we take them into
the actors and it was it was wild it
never stopped
[Music]
swim Peaks when I was a kid and wanting
to be an actor I went to see a razor
head about 25 times yeah I was very very
very keen yeah I don't know how do you
speak David you know we would get on the
phone every night me and his producer
and staff would be helped because we had
best time working with him and we were
sad it was coming to an end and we you
know when one night I was you know on
the phone with her I said can we have
some more she went I'll pass that along
next next day there's another scene
exactly so you look we had to learn it
on the on the on the hoof there's one
spoiler alert scene his spoiler where I
get shot and he had me in a van and and
the note that he gave me and I was
completely laced up with squibs and the
inside of the van was and it was okay
and we were actually on the move so you
could see that see it through the glass
his note to me was Elvis rag doll okay
locked you up okay and that's what it
was and he was not we did in one take
and it was it you know had to be Elvis
but it had to be a rag doll or Elvis and
that was the movement the physicality he
wanted he's so funny I loved him